politically and economically februari
was not for the faint of heart the
situation in Ukraine and particular hat
and still has the world on edge what ads
affected the global economy I'll be
discussing that with heiko Peters of
Deutsche Bank research mr. Peters
everyone the you and your team assess
the state of the global economy
exclusively for made in Germany how did
the day Beck's develop in February and
the demux increased in February in this
pointing to a growth rate of the world
economy of slightly below four percent
I'm so relatively good news and from the
day weeks however China doesn't share in
that optimism what is putting a damper
on the mood in the world's
second-largest economy the falling of
sentiment in China was mainly caused by
one of effect due to the celebration of
New Year's Eve and going forward we
expect that we expect rokom the
sentiment indicator to improve again and
also that we see a relatively good
growth rate in China on an oil and for
this year we expect a solid growth rate
of eight and a half percent so this
falling down is not a severe problem
let's take a look at the eurozone and
the euro crisis the EU Commission
finally expects growth in 2014 after
two-year recession where's that growth
coming from and we see a improvement of
this situation the periphery countries
growth is coming back in the periphery
countries but also the core countries
are still continue to recovery path so
it's a broad bay based and growth that's
coming back but on a whole it's on a
still relatively moderate level and in
which sectors the economy is growing and
that's especially at the moment it was
in the recent quarters especially driven
by net exports but we saw also some
positive signs from domestic demands
that's normally legging the improvement
of exports and the export intriguing and
give thanks to the improvement of the
world economy and with all major reasons
we saw an improvement in the US and
orange
and this is turning our into and pick up
of export growth for European countries
and you already mentioned it even the
southern European debt countries are
improving economically does that mean
that the eurozone has the worse behind
it what would not go that far but we see
an improvement and we see that growth is
coming back in these countries that's a
relatively good sign if you compared
with the previous years but the debt
levels are still relatively high and the
unemployment rates are still on other
history sometime times on historical
peaks and the growth rate that we are
expecting are not high enough to really
push down the unemployment rates and so
in the coming years or the social
problems and I'll still there and when
this will be still challenging years
especially for the periphery countries I
capitis thank you very much for now we
will talk more about that in our
discussion Europe on the road to
recovery is the crisis over you can
write that on DW dot de / mate in
Germany